have I ever advised anyone not to
crowdfund yes not to say that they won't
be successful in crowdfunding at all but
they aren't ready yet I mean the biggest
question is how much do you think I can
raise I don't know how big is your
online audience because you're gonna
need them in order to raise money so if
you have never stepped foot into the
online space you really don't know how
that Twitter thing works or you don't
even have your own personal profile on
Facebook its whoa okay you're not even
close to being ready to start a
Kickstarter campaign first you need to
get back first you need to get that
piece going first you need to be used to
connecting with an audience I'm not
saying you need millions of people but
you need a core group of people because
those are the ones who are going to help
you to spread out you're not going to be
able to spread word of mouth all by
yourself you're gonna have to have a
group of people to do that and it's
gonna be dependent on how active those
people are and how many are they as to
how much money you can raise you know
and and there is no figure if you have
5,000 followers you should be able to
raise $30,000 I know I don't know there
are people who have 5,000 followers and
only a hundred people gave money so
30,000 is not going to you know if they
give $10 a piece you're gonna get a
couple thousand you know you're not
there's also a huge correlation between
the number of people who are lurkers and
the people who actually will take money
out of their wallet and give it to you
and in presentations that I give I show
Freddie Wong as an example he's you know
on YouTube and has raised two times on
Kickstarter significant amounts of money
but if you look at how many follower
subscribers Freddie Wong has on his
YouTube channel it's four point seven
million subscribers so you would think
oh he can raise millions only ten
thousand of those people gave money in
any degree in his last Kickstarter so it
was very lot less than what he has as
his followers so we were talking about
in these recent Canadian workshops the
99 one rule which Julie Giles talks
about she's from green hat digital and
she said 90% of your following are
lurkers there are people who are just
watching
they never participate
they've clicked your page and like and
they've never come back or they just see
you in the newsfeed and they never do
anything about it
9 percent of those people will retweet
you will put a thumbs up next to a
comment or leave a comment but they're
not tight to you
you know they participate but they're
not they aren't gonna convert only 1% of
your super core hardcore fans will ever
do anything to help you that actually
actively spread the word support
everything you do pay money to go to
your events show up if you have a
meet-up that kind of thing so when
you're looking at your stats online and
you think that all those 5,000 people
are a sale you'll be very disappointed
when it when push comes to shove about
how many people actually pony up for the
money so I would say that if you haven't
even gotten started
no no kind of crowdfunding efforts
should be started if you have gotten
started you're gonna have to be
realistic it's better to go over your
goal than it is to not make your goal so
set it realistically you know how much
do you really need to do what it is and
is is that the main goal behind this
campaign is it to raise money or is it
mainly to to build an audience to build
up that participation and money's nice
but that's not the main idea behind this
effort is to to grow beyond your core
because a campaign like that usually
helps you to get more people beyond the
people that you're already engaged with
because they help you and there's an
impetus to it because there's a deadline
as opposed to constantly saying hey you
know retweet my stuff hey share my stuff
you know that that's just kind of an
arbitrary effort if you have a campaign
where there's a deadline and you're all
working towards some kind of you know
goal then there's reason to activate
those people in a certain time frame and
that's what a campaign is you know it's
it's a limited amount of time that
you're doing some effort if money is
your only thing then you're not to be
careful about how much you're asking to
raise because it depends on how helpful
the audience that you already have
gonna be to you
you